yeah welcome to this video on plane desk
in 45 from turkey some hmm yeah let's
play 93 for a change usually I play 92
because I don't really know those
complications too well 24 that's the way
to go if you play for an advantage hmm
okay each one is another tricky idea
trying to quickly gain space yeah you
can take on d4 now and give the check
which is a born sec okay this didn't
happen hmm yeah no creen g4 he won't
learn take on deform this problem
doesn't make much sense
hmm
okay I'm trying to prepare Queens you
fall if you take stakes check I'll play
Bishop the 2 i'd give up the phone okay
he's simply ignoring everything hmm ok
if it takes now on d4 I can take g7 this
was the idea that I'm don't after taking
on defined I'm not in the surf for consi
three on the King under and rook okay
simply moving the king now this is
similar to Queen g4 King evade okay
let's let's try to use this rope quickly
playing rock f3 yeah rock f3 Bishop f1
Queen tix takes e6 yeah maybe try that
maybe it's going to play night at five
yeah then maybe night eat only 2 2 g-3
as mentioned bishop as one I got 26 okay
so hmm hard to say
let's try that maybe there's also night
f4 at some point intending to take on d
50 is just taking it interesting that I
didn't expect it's all so strange in my
book and I can just recapture Quincy 3m
I've got covered the ruckus on f3 and
Quincy to a play Bishop d3 taking on a
five this is excellent I think he just
missed miscalculated something because
taking on d4 is really a terrible move
of you if you don't have anything
concrete now you know he decided to to
grab it came but I have a bishop d three
years now check ya at the Queen D for
Bishop f5 just say please
hmm it's not willing a piece Kristen how
to play this probably just yeah this is
probably the best way it will lead to a
big attack anyway but probably having
rook e1 sir is useful okay let's see the
check first on before or something else
look at five there's also creamy form
i also have Quinn before check and look
you on
maybe that's right look at 525 I don't
really see you win Jamie I completely
forgot about 27 rookie one ah what the
egg okay but Queenie sudden I can't play
also queen bee five maybe we should be
form
probably 9700 well I've got queen dee 5
okay okay let's do that to check now
check
yeah I completely misplayed that this
game should have been over already
pretty sure that I missed some decisive
decisive tactic it's still not not so
easy because he does not have the look
at on edge I didn't play but still it
doesn't feel like I'm winning outright
which was probably possible rookies 7
the idea yeah is his plane without the
rookie it's not it's not easy maybe this
is even ok for what
totaling a bookie 7 and like suckin a
queen queen bee five if he wants to go
and some prevent that let's see what is
coming up with I have cookie seven Queen
f3 or some ideas along these lines
attacking f7 they are taking you'll play
d 3 inches not not so great maybe that
one Queen a three and rookies ever check
check
ting ting t9 money there's no wind I
cannot believe it maybe don't check
maybe that one check check check ah what
a game this will be frustrating if you
look at it with a computer looks look
like every move wins but i just found
the ones that don't win all right wait
resigns okay I'm now show me how I could
have won this is an unbelievable that I
don't win him okay let's let's check it
briefly a check I came
took on a five so what is the right move
wish I boys is the right move and now
rookie one is winning didn't play that
then of course I saw this but I didn't
check didn't see how to win now check ah
yeah yeah typical computer chess the
decisive moopheus bishop to have eight
I'm sorry that this is a this is very
very tough to find completely
counterintuitive but it's if you look at
it it is entirely logical it prevents
the exchange and it pins the night
blackburn low I'm knows we're just
threatening to to win easily and br PP
needs to play the smoothness no other
way giving up the exchange and this is
in fact completely winning as all ports
for oki this is this is tricky to find
there's some other chanting check so
this is in fact not winning okay but i
thought i would have some decent a play
here at least this must be very serious
compensation at the computer only gifts
it is equal amazing it looks like black
is on the ropes but doesn't seem to be
the case check your look ahead win so no
surprise here but I didn't find how
check this is losing okay
and the winners check this one very very
nice yeah very nice but only on a very
good day or with more time on the clock
I'm going to find that move very very
nice if it takes Queen dude she's made
and no defense on g6 I try to make
something simular work in the game this
kind of check this kind of thing but
check it's so clear simply chattering
not really working tlk I'm just just
just download time and that position
three balls amazing really amazing that
this is taking on d4 didn't-didn't it's
this year but this this doesn't lose out
right because it's it looks looks
completely completely insane check the
arcade is close to losing out right of
course but it allows some right edge
requires to find herbs to find those
those amazing computer services that
Jane that this kind of movies this is
just crazy alright thanks for watching